hang on the umbrella president your age
group just to finish moderating the
session on global security and despite
Obama's the Union speech last night
where he talked about the
indispensability of American power I
think it's very clear to everyone on the
panel from all over the world including
the United States that the ability and
the willingness of the United States to
provide the same sort of influence from
a security environment is clearly more
limited that's particularly true in the
Middle East and a half pad Pakistan was
the place that folks with generally most
pessimistic about in part because of our
ice would be a friends they have Saudi
Arabia and China and the Chinese
delegates saying very explicitly not
only will there not be China's boots on
the ground but they're not going to do
very much economically know their
optimism with India Pakistan at the
Indian government I will do its best to
try to maintain the constructive
relationship even as Afghanistan becomes
a power vacuum in the region much more
concerned about Iran the bricks
interestingly very senior saying that an
Iranian nuclear weapon would ultimately
be tolerated if economic sanctions you
say have felt certainly that's where the
Chinese us that is absolutely not where
the Americans are and that's clearly
going to come to a head over the next
few months though some of the biggest
takeaways North Korea i would say an
issue that people are very concerned
about don't have a lot of information on
of course the South Koreans just hopeful
are the things that blow up in their
faces and finally on some mixed opinions
on Russia and with Putin clearly staying
in as the president the potential to
maybe take on board a more reformist
responsive direction after elections
this year or potentially deciding to
cause some trouble in their neighborhood
as to distract the population again not
a lot of decision taken on that one a
very very spirited 75 minutes at this
opening of the daughters are here in
2012 on global security I got I mean
River President appears